I feel really bad not knowing me what's
in a name Disney Princesses when it
comes to yours there's a lot some of you
have the perfect name to fit your
character but others have totally
confusing meanings if you could change
your name and lead a different life
would you or do you love being part of
this famous group of Royals that made
you so many of the Disney Princesses
have names that are just perfect for
their characters but some Disney
Princesses have mysterious secret
meanings behind their names
keep watching to the end to discover
which princesses name relates to a
vegetable Moana we're starting with the
most perfect pairing of character and
name and that's Moana it means ocean
wide expanse of water or deep sea in
Maori and Hawaiian as well as in other
Polynesian languages Disney couldn't
have picked a better name for this
seafaring adventurer I am Anna and Elsa
when you think of this heroine from
frozen you think of a forgiving sister I
love you she showed compassion towards
Elsa even after Elsa harmed her as a
child and left her as an adult so it's
totally fitting that her name means some
merciful given that this character
description is basically the definition
of mercy this Hebrew name also means
gracious to told you it was perfect as
for Elsa her name has different meanings
in different languages as frozen is set
in a fictional version of Norway we can
look to this part of northern Europe for
the most relevant meaning and in fellow
Scandinavian countries Sweden Elsa means
truth that's the case in Spain and the
u.s. too and else is all about living
her truth I never knew it I was capable
of bail some names have literal
translations that are the perfect fit
and that's the case for the heroine of
beauty and the beast'
vowel is the French word for beautiful
and we all know that this movie is about
the differences between what we look
like on the outside versus what we're
really like in the inside he's no
monster guest on you are of course in
Belle's case she was beautiful both
inside and out Merida the heroine of
brave is a complex character so it's
fitting that her name has a complex
meaning it's the latin form of mary
which itself is derived from the Hebrew
name Miriam it's debatable what the name
means
some believe it means sea of bitterness
while some think it means rebellion both
of these definitions fit right in with
Meredith's character she rebelled
against her family and felt bitter
against them to Jasmine
in contrast the princess of Aladdin has
a straightforward meaning behind her
name jasmine is a type of climbing plant
it has fragrant flowers that are used in
perfume and it derives from a Persian
word yep that sounds just right for the
sweet heroin from Agrabah there you go
Aurora keeping with that straightforward
theme the princess of Sleeping Beauty
also has a name with a clear definition
in fact we're even told what her name
means in the opening of her movie the
narrator explains they named her after
the dawn for she filled their lives with
sunshine Ariel there are certain Disney
Princesses names that don't make much
sense and one of those is Ariel it means
Lion of God in Hebrew and in the Old
Testament it's another name for the city
of Jerusalem we can only assume that the
movie makers at Disney simply liked the
name that's kind of pretty
okay there him as we can't find to any
link between the Little Mermaid and
these meetings keep watching to find out
which princess has a totally bizarre
meaning behind her name
Mulan given that the movie Mulan takes
inspiration from Hua Mulan of Chinese
legend there wasn't any room for
invention with her name but it is
intriguing to learn that in Chinese mu
means wood and lon
means orchid remember how Mullins father
talks about the blossoms being late to
bloom this one's sweet perhaps the
filmmakers wanted to bring in a subtle
nod to the floral wood orchid definition
with that touching scene Pocahontas
Boggan this is another Disney Princess
whose name was already in place after
all
Pocahontas really did exist but that
doesn't mean that the secret meaning
behind her name doesn't totally suit her
character in the Disney movie
Pocahontas means playful one in Powhatan
and she sure is playful remember when
she flies down a waterfall she's also
not interested in marrying Coquelin
because he's too serious for her playful
nature father I think my dream is
pointing me down another path Tiana
perhaps Tiana's fate was already written
in those stars she used to wish on after
all she became a princess in the end by
marrying Prince Naveen you just kissed
himself a princess and her name which is
of Russian and Latin origin means
princess amazing writes Cinderella
before she married a prince Cinderella
worked as a maid for her wicked
stepmother one of her tasks would have
been to sweep away the ashes from the
fireplace so it's fitting that her name
comes from the French word said in
drillin which means little ashes as for
her stepsisters Drizella means spirited
and cruel while Anastasia means reborn
anyone who's seen Cinderella to
dreams-come-true knows that Anastasia
does experience a rebirth she learns the
error of her ways and turns nice in the
end
Rapunzel we're finishing up with
Rapunzel and boy does she have a
fascinating secret meeting behind her
name I have to know what they this
German name comes from the vegetable
rampion which is like a lettuce it's the
generic name for a family of plants that
purple flowers that's totally fitting
given that Rapunzel wears purple is that
just a coincidence or do you think
Disney chose that color for her on
purpose so that's a wrap on the secret
meaning behind Disney princess names
which is your favorite tell us in the
comments and make sure to subscribe to
the things for more videos like this one
thanks for watching we'll catch you
later
[Music]